it's a cliche but definitely strange
times I don't know about you but I find
myself reminiscing a lot these days
about the simple things in life that I
used to do before quarantine before the
pandemic so I contacted my friend Andy
Richter and the two of us together
started reminiscing about those times
before quarantine and a little peace I
call what I miss I miss my director
Billy saying of course we'll blur the
camera on your close-ups I miss the
laughter it's like cocaine to me I also
miss cocaine I miss talking to my father
on the phone every Sunday I know the
coronavirus shouldn't affect that but
nonetheless I've decided to stop
speaking to my father I miss that knock
on my dressing room door five minutes
mr. Richter and knowing I still have
five more minutes to masturbate I miss
people coming up to me on the street and
saying hey I loved you as the creature
in Pan's Labyrinth
I miss going to auditions and being told
I'm not Jimmy Dean sausage material I
miss pretending I know my longtime
neighbors name it's not Stavros I missed
my weekly adult cuddle parties even if
they were lightly attended
I miss improv shows I miss hearing about
my uber drivers complicated custody
battle I miss going to the beach and
having my view of the ocean blocked by a
leathery old man in his speedo playing
Kadima I miss taking a walk on the wild
side which was just me dipping a finger
in a stranger's soup to get a taste I
miss the smell of my weird co-worker
microwaving Spanish mackerel
I miss microwaving Spanish mackerel at
work
[Music]